The goal of the HL7 Reference Information Model,
or RIM, is to document the actions taken to treat a patient.
A request or order for a test is an action.
The reporting of the test result is an action.
Creating a diagnosis based on test results is an action.
Prescribing treatments based on a diagnosis is an action.
RIM defines the semantics of a common set of
administrative financial and clinical concepts
in order to describe these actions and foster interoperability.
Here you see a diagrammatic representation of
all the RIM concepts or classes and their relationships.
I provide a link to a webpage from which you can explore them all.
The four shown here are core or backbone classes.
Every happening is an act that is either being done,
has been done, can be done,
or has been requested or ordered.
Examples include clinical observations,
medication administration, medical procedures or patient encounters.
Act relationships represent connections between acts such as composition,
preconditions, revisions and support.
Participation defines the context for an act such as author,
performer, subject or location.
The participants have roles such as patient,
provider, practitioner, specimen or health care facility.
Entities such as persons, organizations, material,
places or devices play these role.
How can a single act class represent all of the elements of a clinical action?
Their definition, requesting or ordering them,
or reporting the result.
This is the role of the Act.moodCode that
specifies whether the act is an activity that is defined,
is an event, has been requested or ordered,
or is promised, or is the subject of a future appointment.
Here's an example of a patient registration message in both V2 and V3 formats.
You will not find anything related to RIM up here in the V2 message.
Down here in the V3 version,
you see processingModeCode Code=T.
Over on the FHIR website,
you can easily find this table that explains
the possible values of this code, its value set.
And T indicates current processing.
So that is the status of this patient's registration.
The state of processing of an administrative task is
but one example of the great level of detail in RIM.
To get a further feel for this,
let's focus on the special arrangement code for this patient encounter.
We see here that this is a leaf of the act,
meaning it is a particular example or instance.
Its value is DSET, D-S-E-T.
It indicates there is a discrete set of possible values.
Again, a value set for this field.
Once again, as you see here,
the FHIR site is a great way to discover these values.
These codes for special things a patient might need at arrival for
an encounter and the possible values are wheel for wheelchair,
add-bed for additional bedding,
int for interpreter, att for attendant and dog for guide dog.